so this car right over here is
approaching an intersection at 60 miles
per hour and right now right at this
moment it is 0.8
miles
from the intersection
now we have this truck over here it's
approaching the same intersection on a
street that is perpendicular to the
street that the car is on and right now
it is 0.6 miles so it is
0.6 miles
from the intersection and is approaching
the intersection at 30 miles per hour
now my question to you is what is the
rate at which the distance between the
car and the truck is changing
well to think about that let's first
just think about what we're asking so
we're asking about the distance between
the car and the truck so right at this
moment when the car is 0.8 miles from
the intersection the truck is 0.6 miles
from the intersection the truck is
traveling at 30 miles per hour towards
the intersection the car is traveling 60
miles per hour towards the intersection
right at this moment what is the rate at
which this distance right over here is
changing
and just so that we have some variables
in place let's call this distance
s
so what we really are trying to figure
out is right at this moment what is ds
dt
going to be equal to
let's think about what we know that we
could use to somehow come to terms or
figure out what ds dt is
well we know we know the distance of the
car and the intersection and let's just
call that distance let's call that i
don't know let's call that distance y so
y is equal to 0.8 miles we also know
that d so let me write this we know that
y is 0.8 miles right now
0.8
miles we also know that d y d t
the rate at which y is changing with
respect to time is what
well y is decreasing by 60 miles per
hour so let me write it as negative 60
miles
miles per
hour
now similarly similarly let's say that
this distance right over here is x x is
0.6 miles right at this moment so we
know that x is equal to 0.6
miles what is the rate at which x is
changing with respect to time
well we know it's 30 miles per hour is
how fast we're approaching the
intersection but x is decreasing by 30
miles every hour so we should say it's
negative 30
miles miles
per hour so we know what y is we know
what x is we know how fast y is changing
how fast x is changing with respect to
time so we could try to do here is come
up with a relationship between x y and s
and then we differentiate that
relationship with respect to time and it
sounds seems like we have pretty much
everything we need to solve for this
so it's a relationship between x y and s
well we know that this is a right
triangle the streets are perpendicular
to each other so we can use the
pythagorean theorem
we know that x squared
plus y squared
is going to be equal to s squared
and then we can take the derivative of
both sides of this with respect to time
to get a relationship between all the
things that we care about
so what's the derivative of x squared
with respect to time
well it's going to be the derivative of
x squared with respect to x which is
just 2x times the derivative of x with
respect to time times dx dt once again
just the chain rule derivative of
something squared with respect to the
something times the derivative of the
something with respect to time
and we
use similar logic right over here when
we want to take the derivative of y
squared with respect to time derivative
of y squared with respect to y times the
derivative of y with respect to time
now on the right hand side of this
equation we once again take the
derivative with respect to time so it's
the derivative of s squared with respect
to s which is just 2s times the
derivative of s with respect to time
once again this is all just an
application of the chain rule
so now it looks like we know what x is
we know what dx dt is we know what y is
we know d y dt is all we need to figure
out is what s and then what d s dt is
the rate at which this distance is
changing with respect to time
well what's s right now
well we can actually use the pythagorean
theorem at this exact moment we know
we know that x squared so x is 0.6 we
know 0.6 squared plus y squared 0.8
squared is equal to s squared well this
is 0.36
plus 0.64 is equal to s squared this is
1 is equal to s squared and we only care
about positive distances so we have s is
equal to 1 right now so we also know
what s is so let's substitute all of
these numbers in and then try to solve
for what we came here to do solve for ds
dt
so
the rate at which so 2 times x
maybe i'll do that in yellow 2 times x x
is 0.6 is going to be 1.2 times dx dt so
that's negative 30 miles per hour so
times negative 30 miles per hour plus
2 times y is 1.6
1.6 times dy dt is negative 60 miles per
hour negative 60 miles per hour and i'm
not writing the units here but if you
were to write the units you will see
that all of our distances are in miles
and all of our time is within hours so
we're going to get an answer when we
solve for ds dt that's miles per hour
but i encourage if you if you want to
actually write out the units and see how
they work out
and so this is going to be equal to two
times s
well s is one mile so it's just going to
be two
times ds dt which is what we're trying
to solve for so what do we get here on
the left hand side
so 1.2 times negative 30 that's negative
right a fifth of 30 is 6. yep that's
right
and then 1.6 times negative 60 that's
going to be negative 96
is equal to 2 times ds dt is equal to 2
times the rate at which our distance is
changing with respect to time on the
left hand side right over here this is
negative
negative 132 is equal to
2 times ds dt divide both sides by 2 we
get negative 66
and now we can put our units if we want
miles per hour
is the rate at which our distance is
changing with respect to time so dtt is
negative 66
miles per hour does it make sense that
we got a negative number here
well sure this distance is decreasing
right at this moment as they approach
the intersection